thank you for your strong personal
commitment to Nato to the transatlantic
Bond and for your leadership not least
when it comes to providing support to
Ukraine and the ukrainians have launched
their counter-offensive they are making
government making gains and of course
this is due to The Bravery the skills of
the Ukrainian forces but the support
from NATO allies is also of course
critical and when we meet in the NATO
Ukraine commission shortly the main
message here will be that we need to
sustain and step up our support for
Ukraine at our meeting and our
discussions here today and tomorrow we
will also prepare for the upcoming a
business Summit where the message will
be about support Ukraine but also the
need to strengthen our own deterrence
and defense this is about new plans new
Force structure and high redness of
forces but it's also about increased
defense spending and I know that United
States has been very clear on this for a
long time and NATO allies have stepped
up since 2014. we have seen that
European allies and Canada have added
350 billion extra for the events and at
the video Summit I expect that allies
will agree and even stronger commitment
to increase defense spending but two
percent will not be a kind of a ceiling
we are striving towards but uh two
percent of GDP for defense should be a
minimum of what we have to spend on
defense to ensure our Collective defense
and our the tyrants and defense as a
strong NATO alliance there are many
other issues to address but once again
Lloyd welcome to Nato
uh
it's great to be back in Brussels in a
nice weather day as well but uh it
really is good to be back here so thanks
for for convening us and thanks for your
leadership it's been impressive
leadership throughout and we're grateful
for your continued service and
sacrifices
um we're meeting in a historic time I
mean this is a a critical point uh in
the in the history of the alliance here
as uh you know Russia's unprovoked
invasion of Ukraine has created the
greatest security crisis since World War
II uh so I look forward to meeting with
allies to talk about uh how we're going
to strengthen deterrence and defense and
uh and so I I'm sure that those will be
healthy and and good discussions we have
a very robust agenda uh based upon what
you've laid out for us and I know
everybody's eager to uh to to get after
it and engage in on that agenda I would
just finally say that I'm very very
happy to welcome Finland to uh to to
Nato and I look forward to sitting next
to a new partner and I also look forward
to another new partner one day in the
not too distant future and we can get
Sweden on board and I know all of us are
really hopeful about that so
thank you so much thank you